Hollywood often makes up stories about nigh-unkillable,
enemy-stomping individuals who laugh in the
face of certain death, only to deliver that
death to countless bad guys instead.
In real life, if you put a single individual
up against a large contingent of well armed
soldiers, the soldiers tend to effortlessly
dispatch said individual, no matter how much
courage and determination he possesses.
But then, there is the story of 22 year old
Herbert K. Pililaau who for one day might
as well have been Captain America without
the shield.
Born into a large 14 child family in the Waianae
area of Honolulu in 1928, Herbert K. Pililaau
was, according to those who knew him best,
a quiet, unassuming child who liked to listen
to classical music and keep to himself.
In a 1989 interview with his many siblings,
Pililaau was described by his family as a
“sweet boy” who “couldn’t kill a fly”,
and his brothers noted that he would often
abstain from joining in with their rough-housing,
preferring his own company to that of others.
In 1951, Pililaau was drafted along with 4,000
other Hawaiians to serve in the Korean war.
Due to his deeply held Christian beliefs,
Pililaau initially toyed with the idea of
declaring himself a conscientious objector.
However, for reasons known only to him, he
decided against this and went ahead and reported
for duty.
During basic training, Pililaau’s peers
were amazed when, against all expectations,
he proved to be the most physically strong
and fit member of his entire company.
Despite this, the 6 foot tall Hawaiian man-mountain
remained stoic and humble, “rarely socializing
with the other men“, spending the majority
of his free time reading the Bible or writing
letters home to his family.
Just a few months after starting basic training,
in March of 1951, Pililaau was sent to North
Korea with the rank of Private First Class
to join the 23rd Infantry Regiment.
Upon arriving in Korea, Pililaau formally
volunteered to be his company’s automatic
rifleman, a risky and dangerous position that
would see Pililaau facing the brunt of the
enemy’s fire-power.
When asked why he was so willing to volunteer
for such a job, Pililaau very matter-of-factly
explained: “Someone had to do it.“
As part of the 23rd regiment, Piliaau and
his company played a key role in the now famous
Battle of Bloody Ridge, in August of the same
year.
However, it was about a month later at the
so-called Battle of Heartbreak Ridge that
Pililaau would go all Hollywood on the enemy
troops.
In the early hours of September 17, 1951,
Pililaau’s position on top of a strategic
hilltop was ambushed by North Korean soldiers.
After a prolonged skirmish, his unit was forced
to retreat.
They then regrouped and charged the hill,
with Pililaau leading the headlong assault.
By midday, Pililaau’s unit were again forced
to retreat by yet another platoon of North
Korean soldiers intent on taking the hill,
which is when Pililaau made the decision that
would make him a legend.
A little after midday, Pililaau turned to
his comrades and told them that he would stay
and cover the retreat.
As the U.S. soldiers retreated, he opened
fire on the advancing enemy with his M1918
Browning Automatic Rifle.
After safely executing their withdrawal, the
U.S. soldiers watched helplessly from about
600 feet down the hill as Pililaau expended
his ammunition.
Out of bullets, he began hurling grenades
at the closing troops.
When Piliaau ran out of grenades, he began
throwing rocks.
When the enemy soldiers were nearly on top
of him, he drew his trench knife and charged,
stabbing with one arm and punching with the
other.
As his squad leader noted,
There was Herb standing up, fighting a lot
of the enemy.
It was hand-to-hand and just Herb against
all of them.
We all wanted to go back up to help him, but
the captain said, “No.”
We tried to help Herb by firing a few shots,
but they didn’t do any good.
All of the sudden, they shot him and when
he went down, they bayonetted him.
That was it.
The next day, U.S. soldiers found Pililaau’s
body… and the bodies of about 40 North Korean
soldiers he managed to kill before the advancing
army had been able to take him down.
For his heroics, Pililaau was awarded the
congressional Medal of Honor, making him the
first Hawaiian to win that prestigious award.
According to his siblings, Pililaau’s family
initially didn’t believe that he was capable
of such a ridiculous act of badassery and
they were reportedly stunned upon hearing
the news that the quiet, unassuming child
they’d known before the war had died in
ferocious hand-to-hand combat.
What didn’t surprise Pililaau’s mother,
though, was the news of her son’s death.
According to Pililaau’s sister, Mercy, their
mother stated she had a dream the night he
died, in which Pililaau came to her and explained
that his time had come.
No doubt every soldier’s loved ones often
have such dreams when they know the soldier
is off at war; but in this case, unfortunately,
hers came true.